Translator: Andrea McDonough
Reviewer: Jessica Ruby
We always ask people,
"What took you so long?"
And this is an interesting question
because when you ask somebody this,
it's completely open to their interpretation
of what you mean.
Sometimes somebody thinks,
"What took me so long
to get to this location I'm at now?"
Sometimes it's, "What took me so long
to get to the point of my career
where I'm at right now?"
And it's interesting
because you get to learn a little bit about that person
depending on how they answer the question,
and I think that's fascinating insight
into somebody's personality.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.